Republicans Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is now hinting at fixing the
deficit problem that Trump and his own
cronies republishes Republican cronies
tax cuts caused by hinting at cutting
Medicare and cutting Medicaid and
cutting Social Security so yesterday we
talked about the budget deficit the
budget deficit is up 17% in fiscal year
2018 over fiscal year 2017 the budget
deficit is set to continue climbing and
climbing into 2019 and 2020 Donald Trump
claimed during the campaign that he
would reduce the deficit that he would
start paying off the national debt but
instead we've had this combination of
corporate tax cuts and even more
military spending if you can believe
that which are leading to deficit growth
I won't repeat it all again since I did
it yesterday but we now understand that
this entire debt deficit thing is a
political football Republicans don't
actually care about the deficit they use
the deficit to slam Democrats but every
recent Republican president has blown up
the deficit Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell told us last year that we
wouldn't need to cut anything to pay for
the tax cuts that they signed into law
because the tax cuts would pay for
themselves what do they mean by that
it's important to understand when they
say the tax cuts will pay for themselves
what they mean is even though the tax
cuts reduce tax revenue they will
stimulate the economy to such a degree
that there will be so much new tax
revenue as a result of businesses just
doing so well and people earning more
money whatever that as the name suggests
the tax cuts would pay for themselves by
generating new tax revenue we know it's
not happening we knew it wasn't going to
happen and in fact the deficit is
climbing and climbing
we now have an idea from Mitch McConnell
about how to fix it and what he's
hinting at is to cut Medicare and to cut
Medicaid and to cut Social Security he
actually told Bloomberg news yesterday
that the reason the deficit is up it's
not because they cut taxes on business
it's not because they're spending more
on the military Mitch McConnell told
Bloomberg that the deficit is up because
they can't get Democrats to agree to it
to contain the spending on Medicare
Medicaid and Social Security which is a
direct hint at we could maybe fix it if
we cut that stuff and in a sense we
could say it's a victory that
McConnell's even admitting the deficit
is up oftentimes Republicans when faced
with the fact that the deficit is
growing they will just claim it's not
they will basically bury their heads in
the sand
he said it's disappointing but it's not
a Republican problem of course how could
it possibly be a Republican problem for
two years now we've been talking about
how the Trump administration and
Republicans right now are coming up with
solutions that don't work for problems
that don't exist yes this is a little
different this is horrific solutions for
problems that they created that's
exactly been trying to do this all along
and I've got to hand it to Democrats I
mean the Democrats along with tons of
other people predicted that Republicans
would pass a bill that increases the
deficit and then they would claim to be
furious about the fact that the deficit
is up blame Democrats and then suggest
cutting Medicare Medicaid and Social
Security to fix it and it's exactly what
they're doing right and exactly as I
used to say so I used to call it
solutions that don't work the problems
that don't exist and I agree with you
solutions that don't work the problems
that you created is the evil genius in a
sense of what's going on here they won't
do it right before the midterms they
don't want to risk putting off seniors
who vote and and poor people who vote as
well and people who are retired who vote
as well but right after the midterms
they will start saying listen we've got
to get serious about this deficit the
president has done his part no he hasn't
it's Democrats who won't allow us now to
balance the budget and then in time for
the 2020 election they'll come up with
something new to distract from the fact
that they either tried to or potentially
successfully cut those programs right
Medicare and Social Security are
overwhelmingly the most popular programs
in the country so they won't do it ahead
of the midterms but regardless of if
they lose the House and Senate they'll
try to push for it after the midterms
either during the lame duck period or if
they retain control knowing that they
have two years to do whatever they want
that's right if they if they're losing
control of the house and or Senate they
will try to push it through and lame
duck and then do like symbolic attempts
to get it through sort of like the six
something that they did to try to repeal
Obamacare when they obviously weren't
going to because the house was
controlled by Democrats under President
Obama but eventually they will have to
move on to something else and claim that
they did their part it was Democrats
Democrats will be the problem no matter
what either because they prevented
Republicans from quote balancing the
budget or because they're responsible
for the deficit having increased you
think the problem would be the military
spending increases or maybe the tax cuts
reducing the government revenue but
apparently that's that's not the problem
and it works out great like think about
if you're Mitch McConnell Kentucky his
state is one of the biggest takers when
it comes to taking federal money versus
paying money back into the system that's
distributed out to the states Kentucky
is the real welfare queen right
referencing Ronald Reagan's story about
some woman with who knows how many kids
who drove a Cadillac and was on welfare
didn't exist the real welfare queen
quote/unquote is actually a red state
like Kentucky and it's all gonna work
out fantastically well for Mitch
McConnell people need to vote is the
conclusion and I want to hear from you
about this I want to hear from you about
if you're voting early which starts very
soon and as soon as in a couple days in
some states I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show follow us both and let me
know what's going on with your voting
plan I am thrilled to tell you that one
of today's sponsors is simple habit calm
slash Pakman where you can go and get a
seven day totally free trial of an app
that I use personally and love I've
talked to you before about the benefits
of meditation just simply sitting there
observing what it is that your mind
wants to do has been a great thing for
me we have so much evidence growing all
the time that this is just a good thing
for people to do and one of the best
tools you'll be able to find anywhere
online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well-deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east
and west you can choose from a huge
selection of five-minute meditations
each designed specifically for where you
are or what you're doing or the mood
that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work
there are meditations specially crafted
to help people deal with anxiety or to
get focused before doing something
difficult and simple habit lets you keep
track of your progress by giving you
feedback about how much you're
meditating how many days in a row you've
been meditating it's a really
comprehensive and well put together app
go check it out you can try it free for
seven days at simple habit calm /
Packman i've put a link underneath this
video